now you consider yourself a bit of a
geek do you not I do you consider
yourself uh is nerd do you prefer nerd
or geek I'm I'm okay with either or I
mean some people like to do my mom you
know what my mom says she says Nathan
you you have the here's your advantage
you you're very geeky but you look
mainstream right that's nice that's
right I'm a mom that's pretty good yeah
it's good what's like a geeky uh
Appliance or a toy or anything that you
have in your life right now that you are
perfectly excited I have four
lightsabers
and you know what I love you just said
that like I'm an alcoholic
I'm gonna
I'm gonna put all my cars on the table
one of the lightsabers actually breaks
in half and it's because it's a double
ended one so I actually have five so
there's five lightsabers in the house
every lightsaber but I but there's a
there is a double I know there's a
double-sided one so you have men you
don't just have one lightsaber and when
you're talking lightsabers you're not
talking the plastic cheap ones you're
talking the high-end you turn them on
they light up like they light from the
end they make the noise
you can tell you can tell when someone
was born when they come over to the
house and they pick one up and they turn
it on just the reverence they have one
in their mind you know they're like if I
was a kid and I had this when I was a
kid it had been over this is all I would
have done ever ever ever yeah and
it's fantastic now you got like a bunch
of people it's just in the right age
group when Star Wars really was
something and and we're all whipping
these things around going this is great
but then you come into it like you're
gonna fight at it but you eat you stop
short because these are expensive
first so you'll have you you get close
yeah
let's do the aftermath of the battle
when one guy's got one arm and yeah
because they're very they're expensive
these are these are very these are yeah
they're not indestructible they make a
noise when they Clash but you just
everybody you think was that too hard
that's not how you're supposed to do it
yeah I don't think what about
um I thought I thought you'd have advice
for us being uh you know a
self-confessed geek uh we are taking our
show to Comic-Con we announced and I was
curious what your take on that was we're
gonna do a our show Comic-Con next year
first of all here's what I love about
Comic-Con the anticipation all year
and then and then everybody's just ready
and it's like a weekend long orgasm
everybody's going oh it's finally here
it's all and and there's just a real
feeling of community everybody's super
duper excited are you are you gonna are
you gonna dress up yes I think so yeah
I've already tested out here I am is
Thor I
I'm ready to go
I'm getting that
yeah thanks for wooing that
sarcastically didn't have the big hammer
no I haven't gotta say I'm not I haven't
gotten the hammer proportions right just
yet you you actually look like a little
kid I look like a child that found a
Thor outfit
hope I don't get caught with this four
outfit